why
so as we pick up a civil war part six
what we're going to find is this build
up this lead up to the finale of the
Civil War event of course we'll see that
as this comic comes to a close that
we'll see that we're led to the very
beginnings of this major confrontation
between Captain America side and iron
man's side well what we're also going to
get is this explanation a little bit of
information in terms of how it was that
this whole Civil War superhuman
Registration Act even started that
Congress didn't simply just arbitrarily
say we should pass this bill that there
was a catalyst to passing this bill
there was someone who came along and
said this bill should be passed or
should be introduced to Congress so that
it can pass but what we see is we start
this story is that we're at a shield
base in Arizona and at the shield base
we of course pick up with a hank pym and
maria hill and what hammond maria hill
are doing is analyzing these engineers
superheroes making sure that they're
functioning the way that they were
designed to do to ensure that no further
incidents like what happened with thor
take place and what hank pym tells us
here is that the superheroes I guess
actions or the view of the superheroes
has to be restored within the eyes of
humanity that people need to begin
trusting superheroes again and so having
these superheroes the ones who have been
engineered and to have them have fake
identities to make them seem as though
they're normal people will go towards
allowing humanity to have its faith
restored in superheroes and that again
these are all going to be part of the
big push they're all going to be part of
the fifty state initiative and so again
with this story this seems a little
underhanded with regards to the actions
of Hank Pym hank Pam and Maria Hill of
course are basically telling us that
they're going to trick humanity into
believing that these engineered
superheroes are actual people and
there's something not going to tell
humanity the truth now whether or not
this is something that will backfire or
something we don't know at the moment
and again it may never be explained to
us but as we continue with this story we
of course see that Hank Pym is called
away by one of the shield agents when
he's in for there's a problem with one
of the superheroes that has been
engineered so of course we see that Hank
Pym leaves Maria Hill to contain
to continue examining the the
superheroes that are currently
functioning correctly at this point we
transition to the Baxter building with
Reed Richards as he's continuing his
work his reprogramming on the cyborg
version of Thor and what Reed Richards
is doing is he's conversing directly
with Tony Stark now of course Tony Stark
is currently outside of the Baxter
building and they're just using a comma
system in order to talk to one another
but of course Tony Stark Tony Sarg ass
Reed Richards how the reprogramming is
coming along and Reed Richards says that
then they've been in surgery for quite
some time they've been working on this
for quite some time and that of course
that the reprogramming should keep this
cyborg version of Thor from killing
anybody else but that the actions of
this cyborg version of Thor in killing
big killing Bill Foster is of course
something they're concerned about but
what he also does is he asked Tony Stark
how everything's coming along on the on
the street level in terms of the crime
that's that's supposedly supposed to be
going down and what Tony Stark says is
that the probability map that had been
created by Reed Richards seems to be
accurate that crime statistics are at an
all-time low and that everything seems
to be going in a much better direction
he also asked Reed Richards about his
meeting with the president and Reed
Richards says that he would he
specifically told the president he would
only become part of the actual fifty
state initiative when it launched if a
Johnny Storm and Susan storm were being
kept from any kind of prosecution and of
course when a Tony Stark asked Reed
Richards what the president's response
was Reed Richards says the president
gave him 12 immunities which he can use
for any individual and of course we know
that two of those will most likely go to
read or two at Johnny Storm and a Susan
storm but as we continue with this story
we pick up again inside of the Baxter
building but in a different part of the
building and what we learn here is that
we're currently following the actions of
Frank castle and Frank Castle was
infiltrating the Baxter building but the
way that he's doing it is very
intriguing what Frank Castle tells us is
that the security system of the Baxter
building was designed by Reed Richards
in such a way to where it would
basically function in the same capacity
as the immune system and the sense that
whenever the blue blue bubbles or these
blue spheres would determine or I guess
detect something that's not supposed to
be there they would immediately attack
and so the suit that Frank castle was
currently wearing is something he had
stolen from a Tony Stark which allows
him to
move through the security system without
actually being detected and so from here
we pick up with both Captain America and
Frank Castle as the two of them are
communicating back and forth when
Captain America says that I guess
informs us that the whole reason for
Frank castle being here is that he's
going to gain some information on prison
complex number 42 which is of course the
complex where the majority of
superheroes and super villains who are
anti-registration are being housed in
the negative zone and Captain America
wants the specifics he wants the
specifications on this prison complex he
wants to know how big it is he wants to
know how much room a have to move around
how its accessed all the information the
Frank Castle can possibly get which of
course Frank castle is successful and
being able to to get four for Captain
America and so from here we transition
to Atlantis with Susan storm meeting
with Namor the Submariner and what she's
doing here at least as is explained to
us as she's looking to gain the forces
of Namor the Submariner for the for the
team of Captain America but maybe the
Submariner is initially I guess a little
arrogant here but is also reluctant to
assist Susan storm here and the reason
why is because he feels insulted he
feels that the idea of Captain America
sending an emissary rather than Captain
America coming here himself is an insult
in the sense that if Captain America is
going to ask for aid from the direct
ruler of Atlantis then Captain America
himself as the leader of the Secret
Avengers should be the one to be here
and asked for that aid but what he also
tells Susan storm is that he believes
Susan storm has an affection for him
that he's noticed for quite some time
that she had been looking at him in such
a way to where it appeared as though she
had an interest of course Susan storm
says no but name of the Submariner says
he can detect the vibrations of her
beating heart and the water and that her
heart is beating faster than it should
now whether or not this is because she
genuinely does have an interest in name
of the Submariner or because he's simply
just attributing her erratic heartbeat
due to her nervousness as being a
romantic interest in name of the
Submariner is not something that's
explicitly explained to us but I would
go as far as to say that given the
relationship between Susan storm and
Reed Richards as tenuous as it is at the
moment that it may very well be that she
does or did have an interest in name
with a sub-meter that she had never
acted on and of course doesn't intend to
act on at this point
I'm from here we pick up with Captain
America and the Secret Avengers once
more and of course we see the Captain
America tells us that name of the
Submariner had turned down the offer of
Captain America to extend aid to their
forces and so it seems as though for the
most part the forces of Tony Stark and
Reed Richards and shield vastly
outnumber the forces of Captain
America's team but what we also see here
is that Captain America is informing or
I guess speaking with the Secret
Avengers with Falcon and others and
telling them that that Frank Castle was
able to gain information about the about
prison 42 he was able to get them the
schematics for the building and that
what they're going to be basically doing
is launching a campaign to free all of
the captured superheroes and
supervillains within the complex what he
tells us is that the the initiative is
going to begin moving in such a
direction that it's going to launch
basically in a very short amount of time
and so their window is constantly
getting smaller and smaller for when
they can actually jump into this
opportunity of freeing all these
captured superheroes and supervillains
but what we also see is that they only
have a couple of the codes regarding how
to access the of the prison system on
Rikers Island because again at the
moment the only method for access to the
prison 42 complex is at Rikers Island
but part of the fifty state initiative
includes having access to the negative
zone prison from every from one major
prison system in all 50 states and of
course Captain America and his team are
trying to keep this from happening and
so as we continue with the story we of
course see one one of the interesting
concepts when we see the Diamondback
brings in a couple of a supervillains
and what these supervillains tell
Captain America is that the supervillain
community has just as much if not more
to fear from what's going on with this
50 state initiative and the superheroes
do the superheroes could choose to
register they could simply just make
themselves a part of shield what the
supervillains will most likely not have
this same opportunity but before either
of these supervillains are able to
actually join Captain America they're
immediately shot to death by by Frank
Castle with no questions asked and so
what Captain America does is he
immediately attacks Frank castle and
Frank hassel says that they were bad
guys that they were killers and they
were thieves and that again his purpose
his goal is to eliminate all felon
anywhere that he finds them regardless
of what their motives are and so as
Captain America continues pummeling
Frank Castle he tells Frank Castle to
fight back but Frank Castle says that he
won't fight against Captain America and
so it's at this point the Captain
America
relinquishes his fighting against Frank
Castle and simply tells somebody to take
Frank Castle away to get Frank Castle
out of here we see that of course that
Spider Man explains that the whole
reason why Frank Castle wouldn't go or
wouldn't fight a Captain America is
because Frank Castle believed that maybe
he had enrolled or he had become part of
the Vietnam War to basically walk the
same path as Captain America did to make
himself equal to Captain America and of
course Captain America says no he says
this is wrong and he says the Frank
Castle is simply just an insane human
being and so at this point we transition
to Stamford Connecticut and this is when
we learn why it was that the entire
superhuman Registration Act had been
initiated in the first place we see that
Reed Richards and Tony Stark are meeting
with with Miriam Miriam and I guess one
of the mothers of the children who was
killed during a Stamford Connecticut and
what Miriam tells us here is that it was
her idea
to launch I guess the superhuman
Registration I could get Tony Stark to
launch the I guess the fifty state
initiative that she's basically the one
who was behind all of this that she was
the mastermind she was the reason why
the build went before Congress she's the
reason why Tony Stark Reed Richards and
Hank Pym had sided with the bill and so
what this does is give us some very
important insight into just how deep
this whole superhuman Registration Act
goes and from here we transition to the
North Pole to dr. Strange's sanctuary
and dr. strange is visited by by The
Watcher and The Watcher asks Doctor
Strange how long he's been here how long
it's been since he is eaten and dr.
strange says basically since the
beginning of the Civil War that he
really hasn't had anything to eat and
he's only drank a little bit of water
and the whole reason why he's done this
is because the idea is that hopefully
his fasting will allow the Civil War to
come to an end with as little bloodshed
as possible but what dr. strange also
tells us here is a very important thing
he tells us that there's no right or
wrong in this debate that neither side
is correct here but is all just a matter
of
active and this is one of the most
hard-hitting points of the civil war in
the sense that in the end it all simply
just comes down to how you view society
how you view the argument of freedom
versus security and so again The Watcher
says that he's very familiar with this
concept the idea of trying to stay out
of things and the recognition that
sometimes there is no right decision
here there is no right way to to decide
who's right and who's wrong and so from
here we transition to the - Rikers
Island and as we continue with this
story we of course see that the
Invisible Woman
is able to help The Secret Avengers
enter Rikers Island when she was able to
make them invisible and so again what
black panther who has joined the fray
says is that of course he and storm were
with The Secret Avengers the whole time
he had always sided with them and that
they'll do everything they can in order
to ensure that the Secret Avengers come
out on top here but before the group
goes to much further of course
spider-man says that his spider sense is
going absolutely haywire that it's going
completely nuts and what we see is that
on the other side of the door that they
are facing when it opens up pours out
the entire forces of Tony Stark as well
as the Thunderbolts and so again we
basically have this confrontation we had
this situation where we have Captain
America's team and Tony Stark's team
beginning to face off with one another
from here we see that Tony Stark says
that they were aware of the actions of
Captain America the entire time they
knew exactly what their plan was because
they've had a mole within Captain
America's Secret Avengers for quite a
while and Captain America says he knows
who it is that he knows his Tigra and
they've known about her for quite some
time but he says that Tony Stark's not
the only person that has a spy on the
other side and what was revealed to us
here is that Hank Pym is not actually
Hank Pym that Hank Pym is Ho chling he
is a shapeshifter and that he had
replaced Hank Pym at the beginning of
this story when we had picked up with
with Hank Pym and Maria Hill in Arizona
now what we can most likely derive from
this is that the the SHIELD agent who
had appeared to Hank Pym and told him
there was a problem with one of the
superheroes was in fact hoechlin in
disguise and once he was able to get
Hank Pym by himself he was able to uh
over over power and incapacitate Hank
Pym and then take his place and Reed
Richards realizes
is a massive problem that if if mimicked
if I'm sorry if if hopefully was able to
access or able to replace hank pym and
able to copy the voice patterns of hank
pam then he's had full authority to
everything that Reed Richards and Tony
Stark has and so what we realize is that
all the cells are opening up inside of
prison 42 and all the prisoners who are
previously being held captive have now
been released and so the forces are
basically at an equal point now or both
teams have the same number of people and
both teams are quite capable and so as
the story comes to an end we see Captain
America telling Tony Stark and Reed
Richards to close their eyes because
this might hurt with that being said
we're going to go ahead and bring this
video to an end I hope you guys enjoyed
it if you did let me know and I will
catch you guys